Now that we have looked at the data can we ask some more questions?
So the first question we want to ask is can we
identify people based on their location patterns?
We have discussed in the previous video that we could use some distance
functions measured at different times to determine a person's location pattern.
To answer this question, we can start using simply x and
y coordinates for their location.
Or use something like a taxicab distance or a Euclidean distance.
We have already discussed the formulas for the taxi cab and
the Euclidean distances.
As you see, we will continue using the flow diagrams to map our
progress through the iterative model building process.
After looking at the data we can quickly draw the following
conclusions about it.
First, the data is labeled.
Secondly, the labels are categories and not numerical.
So we can cast this as a classification problem.
Of course, we can use location and
distance over time to make this classification.
The next thing we need to decide is whether we want to
build a model that is linear or not.
We can use some nonlinear methods.
For example, kernels or artificial neural networks.
However, for this problem we will not go down this route.
We will go down the linear route first.